my name is micah perry and
i am a senior here at hillsdale college
studying economics in german
tonight it is my distinct privilege to
introduce our speaker
mr peter rex peter rex is the ceo of rex
a group of real estate technology and
investment businesses
headquartered in austin texas a graduate
of georgetown university and harvard law
mr rex built his small real estate
investment business into a 1.5 billion
dollar integrated investment and
operations company
with over 500 employees throughout the
united states
in 2015 peter embarked on an 18-month
85 country business investigation to
to understand how to apply his vision of
serving and elevating humanity
at the largest possible scale he is a
founder of the christo ray tampa
celesian high school
which now serves over 175 low-income
students
he is currently building multiple tech
businesses and has nine patents pending
a member of legatus and tiger 21 he has
written for numerous publications
including forbes morning consult the
american mind
and the wall street journal please join
me in welcoming mr peter x to the podium
well thank you for having me i really
appreciate it hillsdale is actually my
favorite college
in the entire world
[Applause]
but you know i've never even been here
before that's my first time
and it gets worse i've never even
read what the curriculum is i don't know
what they're learning i've never
met a professor before so you might
wonder you know how could it be my
favorite college
well it's because i've met some of the
grads from here
and they've impressed me more than other
grads from other universities
whether it's some of my peers at
georgetown or harvard law school later
or throughout my business career we've
hired over 100 i've hired myself
screening people over 100 at least
the students are the alumni as they
graduate are
free thinking they're independent-minded
and they are broadly learned
which i think is the product that should
be produced should come out of a good
education from university from college
so congratulations to you guys
[Applause]
me being here is a little bit of a
little bit irony because as an
entrepreneur i'm
typically like a lot of successful
entrepreneurs a little crazy
not the best rule follower as i
mentioned elizabeth from breitbart
at dinner she was worried about her kid
had you know had some trouble with
montessori school couldn't follow the
rules i said don't worry about it
i was kicked out of montessori school so
and you know all the way up you know
through harvard law school i had
problems with you know not attending
classes
elizabeth warren actually i was in her
one of her classes
had officially failed me one of the only
two students you ever found in her
career
but it's even better because then i
fought back to take the exam and i ended
up passing anyways
so just like trump might
fight back and i know press president
who knows we'll see
but to kind of bring into why i'm here
first first reason why i'm here there's
really two reasons is first
is it's out of self interest i see that
hillsdale is a great university
great college i've seen some of the
produce some of the fruit from the tree
so i know the true
the tree must be great so i want to
build a network with our company and
with hillsdale
a pipeline for future people that could
work in our company
and also be connected with the alumni
for information advantages
understanding things these are
thoughtful people fiercely independent
thinkers
and those are the types of people i want
to get to know and be friends with into
the future
the second reason why i'm here is
because the seriousness of
big tech and its danger that it poses to
us into a free society and i wanted to
convey
my understanding of how it works and how
it's sort of tied together
and propose some solutions
so let me jump right into things here
i've got a bit of a packed talk here so
i'm gonna try to
try to hammer through so keep up with me
here
my topic is the political and cultural
conformity
of big tech i want to give you a quick
overview
of what i'm going to talk about first
i'm going to tell you where this
conformity comes from
there are four essential interconnected
elements
we'll talk about the people who run tech
who they are
where they're from what they think then
i'm going to describe the consequences
of their worldview
there are a few big ones finally
we're going to look at how to break down
the homogeneous
conformity of big tech leadership which
is the key to getting us out of this
mess
and creating a world where tech is
helping instead of hindering
human flourishing tech has
huge potential for future progress and
human advancement
but now it's primarily focused on
objectifying
customers and extracting value from the
masses
with the benefits increasingly flowing
to a
fewer and fewer small elite group
tech offers powerful new avenues to
share knowledge and a rich culture
but today it's rapidly eroding the
cultural norms and eternal truths
on which our civilization stands
faith family freedom tech is undermining
it all
and of course tech has the power to give
more people a voice
but as we've seen in just the past week
tech is actually taking people's voices
away
it's censoring regular citizens
and acting like the gatekeeper of truth
it also censors news outlets and even
the president of the united states
it's acting like it knows what is best
for us to hear
and to understand and it and it's trying
to direct us as to what we can think
is true or false even though we have not
even voted for them or elected them
there's no question that technology has
made us materially better off
all of us no exceptions
but there's so much more to the story a
lot of the most
cutting-edge tech is now in the hands of
a radicalized minority
that is enriching itself by feeding off
of our vices
while leaving the rest of society
morally and culturally
bankrupt
today's tech leadership sucks
period mainly because they're intolerant
their intolerance manifests itself in
oppressive
cultural and political conformity big
tech is imposing a single world view
on the rest of us leading us to a
full-blown crisis
culturally politically and economically
the good news though is we can do
something about all of this
we can transform tech to the betterment
of our country our economy
and our world before we dig in
i want to make one thing clear while
conformity is real in the tech industry
conformity in itself isn't bad per se
conformity can be a good thing look at
the amish
they're a bit weird like myself
they prefer a horse and buggy i prefer a
tesla roadster
some like the charm some like the speed
what's key
is that the amish and i tolerate those
who are different
there's plenty of good conformity
elsewhere too i'm a catholic
we have our own version there's even a
flavor of conformity
here at hillsdale i would imagine
all that's fine because it comes from a
good place and it tolerates
the other and even in the case of
christianity
mandates to love the other
but the conformity in big tech does not
give toleration
for the other the one who disagrees with
their worldview
their ideology is an intolerant ideology
that that's hostile to non-conformists
ultimately their ideology leads to
cultural
and political subjugation to forcing
others to conform
that subjugation is in its early stages
but it's gaining steam fast
the rottenness of big tech has been of
has been obvious to anyone
who has been paying attention but now
because of the election it's become
obvious even to those
who were not paying attention
big tech has flexed its muscles before
the world like never before
and most people are now realizing that
we have a problem
let's turn to where this crisis came
from
tech conformity exists for four
interconnected reasons
the first tech leaders and workers
mostly come from a tiny handful of
universities
that already limits the range of views
and experiences
creating a very small group of people
with a largely similar view with a
larger summary views and training
second these schools indoctrinate
students
and transmit a worldview opposed to
non-conformist
thinking they're especially hostile to
judeo-christian ideas
and the critical thinking it spurs
third tech is mostly located in two
radicalized urban centers seattle and
san francisco
the local culture reinforces what was
indoctrinated at the universities the
politics
and the culture constantly encourage the
same things
and more importantly discourage opposing
viewpoints
as more tech people train to be
intolerant descend on these
two areas the worse it gets
fourth and finally tech is tremendously
profitable
without this extraordinary profitability
profitability
the situation would not exist the tax
the tech industry's growth and riches in
turn generate
massive demand for more of the same type
of talent
which comes from the same universities
and ends up in the same
two locations combine these four things
and you
get a self-perpetuating cycle of highly
compensating webbings
that want to impose their views on the
rest of us
you can see this reality with your own
eyes for my part
i started to see it when i began to get
my hands dirty in the tech world
i've been i've been in business for well
over a decade i got started in my
investment real estate operations in
2005. i powered through
the last economic crash getting my face
kicked in
yet survived to tell the story and keep
building about six years ago i began to
see that technology had the potential to
transform real estate
and pretty much every industry i wanted
to drive i wanted to drive that
transformation
in 2016 i moved to san francisco
and jumped headfirst into every aspect
of technology
the way i saw it was that if i wanted to
learn the most about tech
i needed to be in the center of it all
to understand it from within
i love san francisco the city and the
people are generally wonderful
the natural beauty is also wonderful and
i love the restaurants etc
there's so much in san francisco and
silicon valley that's right
but there's an awful lot that's gone
wrong
and has gotten worse in the past few
years
from the moment i arrived in bay area i
sensed an oppressive weight
of an intolerant ideology it seemed like
everyone thought
the same way about everything and almost
and most alarmingly on things that
matter most
there were basically no disagreements
the tech elite had one view of culture
one view of politics
one view of humanity and one view of
society
they all felt the same way about how it
should look how it should work
and how they should take the lead in
reshaping it
when i was recruiting i realized that
only with great diligence
could i find people who were
independent-minded
and in most cases they were sort of
hiding having realized
their personal views had the potential
of hindering their professional
advancement
after two years in san francisco i left
i realized that it wasn't a prudent idea
to build a massive long-term institution
in a place where free-thinking people
were so hard to find
i also realized i had a large gap in my
understanding of the game
i was missing a gap i was missing a
grasp of the other tech power
seattle that's where you have amazon and
microsoft
and they do things very differently i
was
i was hopeful that in the pacific
northwest i might find a place where i
could set up the foundation of my
companies
so i headed north to seattle with my
wife and two kids
like san francisco the seattle area was
amazing in so many ways
great friendships great outdoors great
times for business
but we ran into the exact same cultural
challenges
in terms of tech it had a massive tech
talent pool
but the ocean surrounding it was
intellectually culturally politically
and morally one-sided
and therefore stifling for free thinkers
just like san francisco
tech is the most innovative field in the
world
but it's now filled with some of the
world's most insular leadership
it's the most dynamic part of the
economy but it's now stagnant in terms
of the views and values of its workforce
we call it big tech and that's true to
an extent
big companies big impact big markets big
profits
it has all that and more but in a
broader sense
and in a more meaningful sense big tech
is small
it is small minded and small-hearted it
is even it even has a small vision for
what's possible for humanity
so what explains this how did the vast
majority of the tech industry become
controlled by a cultural and political
cabal
one that's determined to impose its
world view and is bent on centering free
citizens
and even the leader of the free world
it's not a secret what started with an
indoctrination at the college
has continued and worsened on the
corporate campus
before i explain how this happened i
want to explain how i came to realize
something
i trace it back to a trip in 2015.
i was putting together my plans to
launch a massive venture when i realized
i lacked a truly global understanding
of the world which was necessary
additionally i wanted to see what worked
what didn't and what kind of global
opportunities were out there
i traveled to 85 countries in 18 months
and took over
1 000 business meetings with leaders
across the globe
each country was fascinating in its own
way but i noticed a common thread in
communist or formerly communist
countries
i kept asking myself how did these
regimes maintain
such an evil ideology and control people
so effectively
for so long what made it possible for
them
to subordinate what made it possible for
them to subordinate human freedom and
human dignity
to the state for decades
a big part of the answer was education
or rather the emphasis on technical
education
and the intentional lack of liberal arts
education you see
communist countries put a premium on
stem education
science technology engineering and
mathematics
let's be clear these are important
focuses they're important to economic
and technological progress but on their
own they're not enough
they're all about training how to do
something rather than
how to think
you only get to the why when you study
ethics religion literature history
politics and philosophy
communist regimes intentionally never
emphasize these disciplines and they
still don't
whether it was the soviet union in the
1980s or communism today
those regimes don't want anyone to think
critically about social political and
moral issues
the rulers don't want people to ask
tough questions because then the people
might start to find unacceptable answers
so the rulers push people into fields
that would most
benefit the state they want people who
can build utilitarian and high-level
military
tech like nukes tanks fighter jets and
hacking tools
but not discuss high-level ideas like
truth and beauty
they want minions who can build stuff
but they definitely
do not want free thinking people who can
critically question
why and for what purpose or is this the
right way or wrong way to do things
they want people who take orders not
free citizens
what they haven't realized is that by
holding their own people down communist
regimes
sow the seeds of their own destruction a
society that destroys its
its people's moral and historical sense
will ultimately destroy itself
because it's destroying its own soul
that's one of the most important
realizes realizations i had when i was
traveling
then as soon as i got home to the west
coast it hit me i saw an analogous
problem here
our tech leaders are the product of a
similar system at universities
they are indoctrinated and trained to
execute well
technically but not trained to think as
free
persons now of course there are
differences between american higher
education
and communist education our university
system isn't as
dehumanizing all-encompassing or wholly
directed by the government
but our best and brightest students
still go through a kind of
ideological indoctrination one that's
increasingly hostile to free thought
specifically they're being taught that
western civilization is the enemy
that our ideals are inherently evil the
education these students are getting
claims to be progressive
but it's actually regressive
the result is the loss of learning that
enriches the soul
enlightens the mind and teaches critical
thinking
instead of liberal arts we have the
opposite ideologically driven grievance
training and stem education these
schools no longer educate to help create
free persons
who are able to contribute to a vibrant
society
instead they turn out indoctrinated
worker bees
able to technically execute their jobs
while also
advancing the party line the tech talent
pipeline
draws straight from this system in fact
big tech and its favorite universities
have created have created a feedback
loop they rely on each other for success
the tech companies turn to schools like
stanford and berkeley for talent
because the best stem talent is indeed
there
and the schools themselves keep
tailoring their curricular to give this
to give the tech companies what they
want
helping their students find lucrative
careers
making things even more uniform company
leadership is biased against
hiring conservatives libertarians
religious people
or other non-conforming types from these
universities
thus creating an even more homogeneous
group of tech employees
the graduates of these universities
eventually move into
communities like silicon valley where
they face an even stronger pressure to
conform and develop an even stronger
dislike
for those who do not conform
the media exacerbates it they spew the
same message
as the universities the result is a
resounding chorus
and a constant reinforcement of the same
ideas
each new crop of students is thus less
likely than the last to think for
themselves the college education puts on
the mental blinders
and then the broader community makes
sure they never come off
the gasoline fueling this fire is the
immense profitability of tech
the huge amounts of money being made is
drawing people
into the technology university complex
the profits fund the multiplication of
these intolerant tech leaders
who control the most dynamic and
powerful industry
for too many in tech the mind and the
soul are only half
formed and the missing half is the most
important
far from creating superhumans they're
still stuck in the cave
their education and worldview doesn't
touch the soul
or talk to the ultimate things like life
death
love and happiness it doesn't elevate
our eyes and understanding
they're driving the future but they
don't know the past or the principles
that brought us to where we are right
now
let's recap big tech is now
rotten with intolerance which manifests
itself
in a in a homogeneous conformity
it's a conformity of non-thought on
issues
that demand to be thought through like
say the presidential election
and the integrity of the ballot box but
i digress
now let's turn to the consequences there
are big ones and they're bad for
humanity
the first is censorship big tech isn't
content to stay in its own community
and just police its own thought their
intolerance
demands more so the leaders and
employees of these companies
are driven to impose conformity on the
rest of us
major tech companies are now muzzling
opposing thinkers
and blocking competing thoughts from
reaching the working class and the wider
society
they think they have it all figured out
so there's no need for the rest of us
to think at all big tech is able to do
this because in many cases
it has monopoly power especially in
social media
many tech companies have massive reach
and the more
money they make the further that reach
can extend
this gives them a historically
unprecedented chance to penet
to manipulate the way billions of people
think
and they don't seem to be hesitating to
do so a huge problem
is that big tech lacks accountability
some of the world's biggest companies
have abused their extraordinarily
powerful positions
and there are literally no consequences
that is wrong and this is dangerous
the leadership of these companies has
been trained to think they're better and
smarter than the rest of us
and beyond accountability and their
business success only validates that
in their minds they have reached this
they have reached the summit now they
must hand down the tablets
to the common people below so what's on
their tablets
you may be shocked to learn they look
nothing like what
like what came down from mount sinai
tech leaders have no ethical or
philosophical formation or mooring
so they inevitably attach themselves to
every new movement that comes along
they are proof that chesterton was right
when he reportedly said
when men stop believing in god they
don't believe in nothing
they believe in anything
abortion check gender fluidity
check destroying the traditions and
heroes of our ancestors
check the list is always changing
growing morphing
what they believed yesterday may be
anathema tomorrow
for them there are no timeless
principles just the social justice
just the social justice fads
naturally the principles behind a
flourishing society
have no place in their worldview the
judeo-christian traditions
speak of eternal and unchanging
unchanging truths
on which happiness depends those
traditions make sweeping claims
about how humanity should live which is
why for big tech
they must be swept away hence the effort
to extend conformity as far as possible
the push for conformity is everywhere
politically and culturally
big tech is spending millions of dollars
across the country to defeat candidates
who have any kind of judeo-christian
views
this past election was proof tech is
also backing
radical groups that want to
fundamentally shatter the foundations of
a free society
the current tech mindset is perfectly
fine with tearing down
and rebuilding the world over rebuilding
their world over our ruins
but the biggest way tech imposes
conformity
with their world view is through its
platforms
for instance tech companies have little
issue blocking videos that run
counter to their world view similarly
tech companies like to fact check things
that cut against their own
interpretations
they also set standards that limit
conversation and implicitly cast anyone
who's not a moral political or cultural
extremist
in their same vein as a bigot
and of course tech and of course tech
enforces their worldview
through outright censorship last week
they censored
many for simply asking questions about
the integrity of the ballot box
and they repeatedly do the same thing to
the president
even if you disagree with the dissenter
and even if you think
certain dissenting people are over the
line
it's not okay to muzzle voices
especially at such an important time
if tech is fine censoring the most
powerful government leaders
then imagine how quickly the rest of us
can be silenced
it's worth dwelling a bit on the
censorship of the president of the
united states
it crystallizes just how intolerant the
tech elite are
and how powerful they have become
they don't trust the public to discern
what's true and false
only the attack only the tech elite can
do that
and it's not just trump voters who get
treated that way
to the tech mind trained in those
bastions of intolerance
there are plenty of inferior human
beings who should be shielded from
confusion
and pointed in the right direction of
course
they ignore that finding the truth
requires a free and open
debate truth demands it
the people as a whole are actually
ingenious
and much smarter than the tech elite
especially when it comes to common sense
people will discern the truth if given
the chance
but big tech is refusing to give them
that chance
the environment is bad and it will get
worse before the tide turns
the tech industry is only getting more
monolithic in viewpoint
and aggressive in pushing it the rising
generation of tech leaders
is even more intolerant and steeped in
anti-thought
than current tech leaders as they gain
power
they will use it they have every
intention of achieving
their brave new world if they can bring
you along if they can't bring you along
they will gladly leave you behind
earlier i said that tech so-called
progressive views are fundamentally
regressive i meant that in a moral sense
their views are undermining not
advancing
human freedom and human flourishing
but there's another way that tech
conformity is backwards
big texts big texts intolerance is
holding back true
technological progress
at first this may sound
counter-intuitive thanks to tech we have
smartphones
laptops the cloud high-speed internet
and the ability to instantly communicate
all over the world tech has made our
lives
better and easier in so many ways
but it's also true that tech has not
empowered most people
yes most people have more products
but tech as of recently has not made
most people
more productive instead big tech is
building tools and systems
and platforms that enrich the few while
exploiting the many on the whole
tech has become increasingly guilty of
consumerizing
rather than empowering
the lack of belief in people also has a
huge
impact on how you build and run a
company
if you think of yourself as superior to
the masses then you're not going to
design something
that helps the masses you'll prioritize
enriching yourself even at the expense
of people
if you see yourself as somehow better
then it's not so bad to distract
misdirect and dehumanize those
who are inferior so long as you yourself
benefit
after all your gain is more important
than theirs
because you are more important
more and more people are starting to
realize that something's wrong
people are angry a big part of the
reason is they know
that tech isn't working for them they
see the wealth and power flowing to the
west coast
but they don't see corresponding
benefits flowing their way
they see tech leaders living large while
looking down on the rest
they're starting to see that they're
being exploited to enrich people who
don't even believe in them
no wonder there's a backlash against big
tech
no wonder populism is rising on the left
and right
tech is not fulfilling its promise which
is to help us all
unleash our true potential we were told
that
it would deliver for us a new and better
age
it still can while generating returns on
a global scale
but that truth is the is now
considered tiring for most of society
and they are sick of waiting
and we've covered the problem which if
you recall has four parts
most of the tech elite come from the
same universities
those universities indoctrinate against
truth
and free thinking and encourage
intolerance resulting in increased
conformity
the tech centers in seattle and san
francisco reinforce
that conformity and tax profitability is
the gasoline that feeds the fire
creating a massive demand for more tech
jobs which drives that cycle faster
we've also covered some of the
consequences
an empowered smug elite with no
accountability
that's fiercely intolerant of opposing
viewpoints
is using its massive market power to
dehumanize sensor manipulate and
ultimately control people at scale
now let's talk about the solution
there is a solution good
will always triumph over evil
and it is in our darkest hour that the
dawn begins
we are at that dawn now but i want to be
clear that enacting a solution
won't be easy the path forward is a long
one
it'll take years likely decades almost
all true solutions to big
human problems take at least a decade to
implement
and a lot of fighting to overcome
so where do we start well politics
is a rear guard action it's important
but it's a last
ditch attempt to defend our freedoms a
throwing up of walls to keep out the
incoming rush of waters
this these efforts are necessary but
will not save us in the long run
politicians and bureaucrats by our own
systems design
are unable to strategically attack and
implement the solutions
necessary
many politicians right now are
rightfully focused on trust busting
and free speech protections but that's
not sufficient
they're focused on the symptoms instead
of the disease
you can break up tech break up tech you
can break up a tech company
into 50 smaller ones but each one is
still going to be run by people who are
hostile to the principles
of human dignity and flourishing
we need to look elsewhere
one place to focus is training people to
critic to think
critically bad schooling got us into
this mess in the first place
but empowered education can help get us
out
we let communist socialist annihilus
train an entire generation of students
and now those students
have been put in charge of the industry
of the future
this cannot be repeated
a better education would teach the truth
it would ground every learner
even those studying stem in the lessons
of history and philosophy and literature
they would encounter the world and human
nature as they are
not the way some ideologue wants them to
be
an education like that breeds a kind of
humility
about our own limitations and about the
limitations of human
action and perfectability it opens us up
knowing our own limitations to listen to
opposing views
which is the only way to achieve the
truth
ultimately we need an education system
that properly
orients us to each other and to our
creator
but education isn't enough either not
nearly enough
we also need to focus on
entrepreneurship
we need people of action innovators
engineers and investors who will do
what current tech leaders won't do
perhaps or can't do
we need them to believe in people and
build technology
based on that belief this is the one of
this is one of the greatest
opportunities in the world
and it's where i'm focusing my energy
and resources
tech was never destined to take this
divisive dehumanizing road
it went in that direction only somewhat
recently
historically many of the great software
companies
filed a more humane approach they
created
general purpose applications for a
broader user base
like microsoft's office suite and at
apple steve jobs
famously wanted to help build products
so simple
that a child could intuitively use them
he developed some of the finest hardware
and software products in the world
tech leaders have lost that spirit and
sensibility but it can be found again
if that happens the economic upside will
be massive
tech has the power to free people from
drudgery and leverage our god-given
creative abilities
instead of spawning addicts we can spur
positive and productive action instead
of pushing people toward
obsolescence we can unlock opportunity
instead of distracting users we can help
workers to focus
and be more productive i'm convinced we
haven't even scratched the surface of
what is possible
we will find ideas and innovations that
are even
more lucrative beneficial and
transformative
than the ones we found so far
instead of tearing the country apart we
could use tech
to bring the country together in short
we could use technology's enormous
potential
and reach a future better than many have
managed have imagined
to conclude a little drink
to conclude there are three things we
need to do to break
the stronghold of the current intolerant
big tech leaders
one train people to think critically and
encourage
diversity of thought a diversity of
thought is essential to innovation and
progress
conformity stifles that so we need to
combat it
tech doesn't need any more non-thinking
ideologues
we need people who are trained to
critically think ask
tough questions and find answers
just to be clear i don't think that
training people to think
should only or even mainly happen at
universities
we need a multi-pronged approach that
includes k-12
the workplace and efforts at the
community level
but colleges and universities do play a
part
i hope that more of higher education
follows hillsdale's lead and empowers
students
to think that would do a lot of good for
tech
and society as a whole
two we need two we need to invest in
free thinking
tech entrepreneurs especially
judeo-christian types
who are poised for leadership they are
the future tech leaders that we need to
win
the task of finding and fi and funding
these future innovators is the
responsibility
of enlightened investors the ones who
are willing to consider the common good
and want to make their money alongside
people they believe in
company leaders also have a
responsibility
to select and empower people who are
grounded in liberal arts
capable of capable of critical analysis
and have a strong enough character to be
contrarian
that's the kind of person who will
develop tech products and platforms
that dramatically improve life and who
will live
and who will ultimately promote timeless
principles
the third and final thing we need to do
is build an
alternative tech power structure
specifically we need to do so outside of
silicon valley and seattle
my view is that the next biggest tech
opportunities are best built
in places where the soil is rich
with people who are looking for ways to
serve people
and not master them
a place where diversity of thought
judeo-christian values
and human flourishing is being
cultivated
and i'm putting my money where my mouth
is i already told you that i moved to
san francisco
what i didn't tell you is that we
recently moved to seattle as well
it happened this past summer we made
this decision for many reasons
but foremost was the need to have our
company
built on a foundation that we have
confidence in for the next
30 years so we left
our company headquarters is now in the
strongly free
state of texas
[Applause]
i don't have my gun on me so you guys
are fine
but i do have some at home now that i'm
in texas i had to do that you know
ultimately i have great hope in the
future
we will take leadership from big tech
we will empower new independent minded
and humane leaders
we will promote a worldview and ideology
far more attractive and grounded in the
truth big tech
doesn't stand a chance they can only
speak to computers we
can speak to the soul thank you
now can we do that nine times more than
normal like the thing
thanks guys
man i haven't written stuff since uh
back in law school it's pretty tiring
nah it's an important topic and i
figured i had to had some things to say
and i've seen a lot of things so
important to communicate it with you but
uh i don't know what the agenda is but
if there's any questions stuff like that
we've got a beautiful young man over
here yep you can make your way to the
microphones
if you have a question okay
i was going to ask the international
dimension of what you speak
most of your comments were very us
focused yet
these big tech companies operate i mean
you know many more customers outside the
u.s
than in the and when you talk about the
gigantic leap of a couple thousand miles
why not bangalore why not
western europe why not south america why
not but
and i do note that you've spoken very
positively of
jack ma and alibaba so do you think the
chinese are the model
that that it's better i think you know i
answered that one
no no very good question though now i've
been to all those places bangalore i've
been to hyderabad
i mean when i went to these countries i
also went to the cities the major cities
so i went to about nine cities in india
about 10 or 11 or 12 or something in
china
um i try not to insult specific
countries too much because some people
get offended if they're from there you
know so
but it was good to leave china when i
did it felt great
now jack ma is kind of an exception to
the rule and in fact you know jack moss
from an area called hangzhou
hangzhou was a territory that was um
received missionaries in about the 15th
and 1600s
jesuit missionaries and later on other
missionaries and it's it's
interesting because the way he speaks
sometimes as very you know
judeo-christian
themes to it so there might be something
to that now later on you know 100 years
later they kicked out the missionaries
and the christians
but there could be some of that in that
soil in hangzhou where where alibaba
sprouted out of and and in alibaba and
jack my really had conflict with them
but let me jump into the question though
i can i divert a lot and
segue but yeah so the reason why i
located in texas is because look i'm
still long america you know i know we've
got a lot of problems
this election is a mess you know i would
like to put myself forward as a
president united states instead of
buying north trump if anybody wants to
vote for me now
it's a little late but um
the um yeah it's a mess but i think
we're it's it's really exposing a lot of
things for people so it's kind of a good
thing but
i still am long america and america is
the center
of the world and we are the most
powerful country probably in history
we are the most powerful country in
history uh because we can reach given
technology and other things
everywhere and every person throughout
the world right even north carol
even north korea nowadays right so we're
and the rest of the world all watches us
and
all uses our tech products and the
leading technologists are in seattle and
san francisco
there are some good leaders in china and
other things and china has done very
well in tech
but it's kind of within their closed
enclosed system that they're doing well
they haven't been able to move their
tech outside of there with the exception
of tick tock now is doing pretty well
but um they haven't had much success in
moving their technologies
outside of the you know enclosed system
of china
now chinese the chinese have great
engineers because they focus on stem
which i
touched on here uh communist countries
focus on that so heavily so that some of
the best engineers come out of china
and and russia now the chinese tend to
hold their engineers because they don't
move out as much
but the best the best of the best talent
when they can they end up in
this country um and microsoft amazon
google facebook these guys have so much
cloud so much power that they're able to
set up almost
you know quasi-governmental
relationships with these countries to
get
some of the people into the our country
on temporary visas or even they have
something just north of the border in
canada that's a huge campus for
microsoft or they're in vancouver
working but they're really working for
amazon and microsoft so so we really are
from this very small area
out of tech in san francisco having the
big massive impact and it's all coming
from there
now where to set up a headquarters why
why texas well i kind of explained that
i think that the culture is very strong
very freedom loving very defensive of
their own values
and they love they love the things i
love which is god family business those
are the three top things right
and they love all that stuff and their
culture so
and it's central to the country so it's
got a lot of other things
and if i was to set up in bangalore i
mean india's got its own problems
i mean we think we got problems in this
country yes relatively speaking maybe to
the last
10 years or whatever we've got problems
for 20 years but if you go to india and
you go to other places i mean these
places are
you know have a lot of significant
political problems
even moving between one state to another
has
serious problems within india it's not
quite so much of an
it's not like china where it's just like
one enclosed single system
it's almost like different countries
within india but i'm getting kind of um
off on a different segue but that's
that's why i chose here and
internationally there's not even really
a second
if i had to pick a second place would be
something like berlin
berlin has a great ecosystem of talent
um
very essentially located now for europe
russia is not as bad as people say it is
have been throughout russia
a lot more free nowadays and people you
know they've they've suffered and come
through communism
they're on the other end of that and
um there's a there's actually resurgence
of christianity there
right in moscow's uh you know red square
you've got
a cross you've got like an old monk the
one who brought christianity there a
huge statue of him too so that's all in
the last five ten years or so
so the orthodox christians are coming
back and resurging there so
anyways i'm kind of all over the place
here but that kind of gets to why
so the first thing i was going to stay
in america was the big picture question
and then within
america we decided okay where within
america we pick texas where within texas
we pick austin
austin's pretty liberal but i'm okay
with seeing different sides of the views
and i like to have that and i actually
don't consider myself necessarily
a conservative i consider myself someone
who seeks the truth and oftentimes i'm
labeled as a conservative throughout
college and
law school but i also i just don't even
take a label i said whatever
because i don't like to think from a
label i like to think from a standpoint
of
what is the truth and then trying to
find that so
too long of an answer sorry but thank
you though that was a good question
well thank you for speaking with us uh
it's good to hear from a fellow texan
i'm from the houston area
my question is i'm a texan now already
wow thank you i appreciate that
my fourth kid will be born soon and i'll
be the first texan in the family
so well congratulations regarding
streaming services and social media
specifically
how can we respond to the epidemics of
distraction and isolation that we see
when you engage with those platforms
yeah yeah it's um it's tough i mean i
think first is to recognize our
own human weakness that they're playing
to our vices
and you know if we were perfectly
virtuous then we would just be like oh
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna take a look at this
distracting text or whatever it might be
right
um what i i'll tell you what i do
anyways is
i put my phone very far away from me
like put in the basement or something
or if i'm at work i like put it in a
random spot i often forget where it is
so it's i actually got i told my
assistant which you'll see right now to
get a bright covered case because i
always forget where it is so i can
spot it but i'll just like put it off
and leave it somewhere you know
and i focus on the work at hand in the
morning like my family i'll just like
not have a phone with me
and we'll just focus on family time for
an hour or so that way we get that in up
front
when i'm praying same thing i just don't
have it around me because it's tempting
you know and we're human so it's better
just recognize
it's kind of like you know if i'm a
single guy i'm not gonna go like you
know
live right next to you know like a strip
club or something crazy or be around
that right
so i mean you know how guys are right
not like me i was never like that but
other guys
the um but i don't think that answers
your question there
yeah so i think getting back to kind of
recognizing the humility of your own
weakness
then building around that the other
thing is the isolation's a big problem
man a lot of people
are depressed there's like i think one
third of clinically depressed now and
another thing i saw recently but maybe
that was a fake poll
but uh anyways that was probably not a
fake poll because there's no incentive
to create a fake poll so it's probably
true right
and that's where i mean we've got to get
back to i would say
coming back to basics of like getting
together for fellowships getting
together for
book clubs and people are meant to be
together
you know even our immune systems fire
off much better when we're together
and the best protection even against
certain viruses is having a strong
immune system there's millions of
viruses every day you come across right
so
i'm not an expert in this um i shouldn't
talk about it but the point is
we we need to keep healthy man the
biggest risk is we don't live now you
know we're going to be like
kind of isolated advertised by
technology and then further
this kind of isolating ourselves from
some of the fear
that's kind of driving people so okay
questions the speaker's end
questions to the speakers left oh okay
it's very impartial like this
i was going to ask about what your views
are on some european countries and their
tactics for
tackling these social media big
companies
like having users be given the option by
law to have those companies purge their
data
like facebook's data on them in their ad
tracking
or some of the other countries in europe
like finland with their
right to the internet but they're also
in the eu working on
tackling big tech giants control over
social media
yeah could as a little muzzle to how
you're saying that could you say it one
more time
or maybe the person is receiving you can
repeat it but
it's kind of a complex question but yeah
good what are your
views on the european nations and their
methods of tackling
social media regulating trying to
regulate trying to regulate them and
make it by law so citizens can ask for
their data to be purged
from sites such as facebook or twitter
yeah yeah yeah so what you know what's
my views on
basically regulating big tech how do we
go about that
you know i mean look in general um i
have a very strong libertarian vent to
me
you know avoiding labels so that's
probably true
um i hate i hate the i you know i hate
rules i hate
the government i mean you know i love it
but whatever but i don't like following
people tell me what to do you know
that's another good thing about being in
texas right less of that
so seattle they're like telling you what
to do about stuff right san francisco is
even worse they try to tell you like
you know you can't do a lot of things
it's pretty annoying but but that being
said look we've we
we also need to protect free speech
right so there's kind of like
you know you've got yes i want i want
less regulations everybody does right
and and generally government's not good
at coming up with good regulations but
you know on the other hand we need to
maintain free speech
and we can see that the free society is
actually at risk
if we don't do so so we've gotta now i
think
do something we've got to put in some
regulations now i don't know the
specific laws in
in europe and uh you know finland
uh which is part of europe i guess well
scandinavia but
i would say that uh you know i can't
speak to them honestly and
in general you know i i try i've tried
to avoid law as much as i can since i
got out of law school
and that was you know like 10 years ago
so i'm kind of
you know right you know i just i don't
even know the specific thing about it
so i can't speak to it but generally i
would say the broader
theme would be that we're going to have
to regulate them and that's it
there's no other way around it because
we got to protect a free society
thank you so much for your talk peter i
really appreciate it and i also agree
with many of your points
especially that there's a huge problem
with kind of this
overflow coming out of progressive
schools moving into big tech do you
agree with
all my points are just many all of them
so thank you but okay
i will venture one more i do think that
there is some fault with
some of the conservative schools like
hillsdale and that when you actually
look at our graduating classes
for some reason a very very small
minority of students actually go and
attack the majority
go into politics econ law which are all
great professions
but for some reason not many are going
into tech so
i guess i have two questions for you why
do you think there is
kind of a lack of students that have
been
liberal educated in the liberal arts
that are going into tech
and what can you do to try to promote
students that have been educated in the
liberal arts to pursue tech
instead of politics or law
yeah so to rephrase that so everybody
gets that is basically you know what can
i say to students that are
you know want to have a positive impact
in the world to
you know consider that dc is not the
only option right to have this impact
what i'd say is they've got a and the
choice is an obvious
initial on its surface choices i want to
have an impact i'm going to go to dc
in fact when i started in college i was
at ave maria college in michigan
and i spent two years there and
i ended up transferring to georgetown
because some of the influence from the
professors they'd recommended i might
need to get
you know a brand name or something to
help me if i'm going to have an impact
and so i ended up going to georgetown
university for that reason i transferred
in
and i thought i'd go into politics so
it's kind of like the obvious one right
but the reality is one thing i noticed
there is that a lot of business leaders
are the ones behind the scenes sort of
kind of calling the shots
um in dc that's something i picked up
unnoticed
and but more importantly what you've got
to do is as a student graduating you're
like you know 22 or 21 whatever you are
20.
you look out and your your projected
life is going to be you know in your 80s
or 90s
that's actual tables from insurance
companies and they generally don't lose
bets so you're probably going to live
about that long right so if that's the
case
then you should probably think very long
term politics is very short term so it's
an obvious thing if i go do this if i
fix it if i can get trump in then he'll
get supreme court justices and that's
good
and the one good thing about supreme
court's justices is that they last for a
lifetime so it's actually kind of a
longer term
almost like hole in our system in a way
but the rest of its passions check
passions
so you know you push in and you get
obama okay
cool you win great everybody was so
happy in the streets when they got obama
in cambridge when i was there but i was
like jesus or something man
um anyways and then trump comes in and
it was like
i was in san francisco when that
happened i actually brought my kids out
to the bar because i was like i gotta
just
i mean they're kind of too young for a
bar obviously but i was like i gotta
just see what's gonna happen it's going
to be funny
so because i had to deal with them all
like thinking jesus came and now they
thought satan arrived
so it's not neither one of them are
satan or jesus right but
they don't the um you know it's very
short term and then you know you get
trump and then maybe get another
reaction later and it
sort of fights back for then it's
important we need to do it and if we
don't have these protections then they
could take
our freedoms and stuff right but the
longer term gain as we get
game is we've got to take position in
areas that are
going to influence people's hearts and
have control over key industries because
those will last and those will be
and who's running those is going to have
a big impact on who ends up in
government
and who ends up in offices right because
they control some of the purse strings
and tech also controls a lot of what you
see and kind of
it's slightly biased one way or the
other so it's important to get people of
goodwill and enlighten to get in there
and i'm not saying it's like the only
thing is we got to get in tech and it's
going to save the world
no but it's absolutely critical if we
don't do it then we're going to have
huge problems that we will not succeed
there's other things too we've got to do
as well you know like education stuff i
touch on some of these things
and in education you know it's right for
creative destruction as well it's got to
be rethought how they're doing things a
lot but i'm not going to get into that
but and i'm not an expert there so
whatever
but um i would say some of these longer
term threads
have a have a bigger longer lasting
impact and some of the students should
be thinking about that
because they're going to live a long
time yes they won't be an immediate ramp
up but if they get in there and they
work their tail off they can rise up
within
technology and come up towards the top
and take over
that takes vision that's all thank you
we have time for one final question
thank you so much this better be the
best questions the last one um i have a
question for the entrepreneurs that you
said that we need
to um challenge big tech companies and
to make that market more competitive
what are some of the barriers to entry
in that market and can those be reduced
or
should we even reduce them
i mean barry is the entry this this
country's got so many great things about
it right you can
you know we're all tremendously much
more wealthy than we realize in this
country that
um everybody here is even if you're in
the middle income you're still in the
top five percent of incomes of the world
you know there's 6.7 billion other
people out there
but you're already in a great country i
think it takes you've got to have vision
for yourself
if you want to go into that and
entrepreneurship is not binary right you
can go into an entrepreneurial company
our company is entrepreneurial and
it's it's very difficult you get in
there it's very very stressful
um not that i don't do that
intentionally it's that we're we're
pushing so hard we're moving so fast
creates a lot of stress right so you're
not gonna have the comfy sort of
bureaucratic job and a nine to five type
thing but you will have
excitement and you will see change
quickly and it will compound on itself
and it's and you will you'll be
exercising your creativity a lot more
but so you can channel that
entrepreneurial desire to have that
oversized impact with your life in a
company that's
like my company because and i'm selling
my company all you guys because i want
some hillsdale people but
there's other companies like this as
well they all suck though um
no but you know you come in a company
like this and you'll be challenged
you're gonna grow a lot
and you will have an outsized impact and
you'll be creating something that is new
and it's changing and it's all
it's gonna cause and creative
destruction where it
it will supplant other existing
companies that are out there so or you
can go and start your own thing right
and if you do either one you've got to
have a vision for yourself that
you start at a and when you're starting
you're not as good
and you're going to get your face kicked
in i mentioned this i got totally
beat up big time in my first few years
in business i mean i thought i was great
the first couple years and i got my head
handed to me really hard
during the crash almost went bankrupt
barely i barely avoided it
but um you know you just got to have
this vision for yourself
and you got to brace yourself mentally
that it's going to be you know
really really hard and not like it says
in some of those books or people talk
about it oh it's so cool
you know these guys geek guys and like
you know shorts and whatever they're
doing nothing i mean i wear shorts i
wear sandals
you can see me right here i'm wearing
like a t-shirt right and this is
actually church hill so
this is a a t-shirt we made that's
churchill on here so
i was happy to see and it says invictus
on the bottom which means
uncomparable um but
you know i was i was happy to see a
bunch of churchill things around there
kind of confirmed my
suspicion that i like hillsdale a lot so
um
but yeah you've got to have long-term
vision for yourself and you've got to
have that mental
preparation that you're going to get
you're going to have go through a rough
time
it's uh you know learning the learning
the pain of it all but
it's like growth pains like you're
growing in different ways and if you
stick with it then you will have an
outside impact
so thank you yeah thank you
you